[Music]
All right.
Hey, so great to see everyone here at AI
Engineer World's Fair. Andre and I have
the honor of curating the graph rag
track which is happening here. And I
thought I thought the jokes Simon had
about bugs were
spot on.
Spot on. Hilarious. And that's the
reason why we care so much about getting
really good data like like building a
solid foundation and good grounding for
models. And we're going to we're going
to chat a bit because I think we have a
social responsibility. We're we're
getting so close to AGI as a as an
industry. We have a we have a social
responsibility to to kind of see what
the boundaries and what the limits of
there are of this. And as proper
computer scientists,
the answer is always look at science
fiction for the answer.
Look to the past to see the future.
Exactly. Okay. So, play along with us.
What we're going to do is we'll each
play off a riff on a sci-fi meme. Give a
big round of applause. Either if you
think it's true or funny or if you just
like the movie. All right, you're up
first, ABK.
Okay, starting off with Momento. In the
Momento, the main character has really
bad short-term memory. He has a specific
disease, so he can't remember what
happened 15 minutes ago. This is the
essence of prompt engineering.
All right. Round of applause.
[Music]
Okay. Okay.
All right. Skynet, the mandatory
fear-mongering.
Even without evil intent, autonomous
systems can make reasonable seeming
decisions have awful unforeseen
consequences.
Uh, okay. That's a little bit. All
right, your turn.
Okay. The Matrix, of course, for New For
now, agents live in a simulation that
we're creating for them. Will we notice
when they flip the script and we're
living in their simulation?
Oh, I think that's the winner so far.
That was close. Off to you.
All right. Howal warned us about trust
issues, lack of transparency, misaligned
goals, the erosion of human oversight,
and the potential for deception.
Okay.
This is very short. Are emotions a bug
or a feature?
It's my personal favorite. I love this
one. Okay.
Okay. So, we got a little monster
reference here. What are the obligations
and social responsibilities of the
creator, us? Should we be kind or
threatening?
Costing tokens.
All right. We'll take that as a flat.
Okay. Your turn.
Ah, the Terminator. Should we go ahead
and just invent time travel now?
All right, we we got a big thumbs up on
time travel
time travel. Okay, go.
Okay, a good Star Wars one. Can AGI
truly grasp the nuances of human
language and culture or forever
misunderstand the meaning of sarcasm and
idioms
and amazing jokes.
Okay. When AGI arrives and we finally
have a globe spanning multi- aent system
with the hive mind, will we be
assimilated or will we be pets?
Okay, last one.
Um, just like Deep Thought's famous
answer, we might have the tools to build
AGI, but do we even know what the right
questions are?
All right, so that that one was good as
well. All right, so come by the graph
track. We're going to reveal which of
these 10 memes are solved by graphs and
graph technology and join us in Golden
Gate B. Thank you very much.
Thank you everyone.
[Music]